remember our buddy uh remember our buddy
mark lane oh yes who by the way i made
the mistake of subscribing to and now i
just get 500 videos a day of him
updating us on his subscriber account
fans this is mark lane
the mega man x4
iris fan here and
i want to say thank you so much
to 1249
nice subscribers
you guys are awesome and supportive
and everything else and thank you again
to 1249
subscribers everybody
really nice of him did you know did you
see his uh his new matchup
did you miss his new matchup no wow this
is a good one
look at this here and paul london
is making his custom wrestling showdown
debut paul london
against orlando jordan and a finisher
only match up here
and paul london with a super kick
on orlando jordan by the way two
absolute jobbers like i don't know why
you would have those he's putting him
over he's giving him a big push
like that means that sometime
within like probably 15 or so years ago
you went out and
you bought a paul london action figure
paul london owes him a personal letter
thanking him i'm working on getting him
a ring
for his toys lando jordan with a knee to
the head
and now these two men are exchanging
blows again
backdrop that wasn't bad orlando jordan
with another knee to the head
i know these two men are excited that's
a good way to break your toys man
you're hitting them really hard against
each other it's a paul london
action figure yeah you're right how
could how expensive can i actually no
it's the paul london one that would be
worth money
because it's right isn't it the ones
that oh the real one
yeah he um
he has his ongoing thing where
it's uh it's seth rollins
it's called seth rollins for hire
and um well
i'll i'll show it i'll show it to you
this one this one's fun
this is a fun one so uh in his world
seth rollins is
is working regular jobs because he's not
doing well in wrestling apparently
so i like his world yeah and this is
mark lane here
with my 14th episode 14th
up seth rollins for hire number 14
and today's episode is seth rollins
works at kfc any beast rude to eight
customers
he's rude and he gets fired by homer
simpson and this video
was requested pretty sure by trenton
wade
of course it was
of course it was of course it was
thank you trenton why would homer
simpson
i thought he worked at a nuclear power
plant ask trenton i don't know
i hope you guys enjoy it and don't
forget to subscribe
me and the 14th episode
of seth rollins for hire number 14
enjoy not the episode starts that was a
preamble
hello welcome to kfc
how can i help you i would like to get
a box of popcorn chicken
french fries okay and a pepsi please a
combo
okay and except for others it's like how
about i [ __ ] your mother in her mouth
jesus he said he was gonna be rude to
him
and a pepsi please okay
that'll be ten dollars please it's
expensive but i only have five
dollars wait that means you can't why is
seth rollins at fault here
we'll see okay so i've watched a lot of
these right at
every single one and one seth rollins
was working their kroger the other one
was working at like
other fast food place they always get
mad at him because they don't have
enough money
we have five dollars that means you
can't get it
ricky miles then i'm leaving
good now the customer walks in
he's getting the customer here real
quick so you guess what's going on
welcome to kfc daniel bryan how can i
help you
why is so you're telling me all these
people are going to kfc and not one of
them is like
wait a minute aren't you seth rollins
especially other wrestlers because other
wrestlers are the ones going they would
know who he is
like yo question right i'm going to
order some chicken that's fine but
what is becky lynch's butthole tastes
asking for a friend
i would like i would like to get five
honey barbecue wings well daniel bryan's
a vegan so he wouldn't do that
and then seth rollins says you were
never over
your yes chant was over you were never
over
with french fries and a mountain dew
please
i'm sorry we're out of mountain dew
no you're not i saw people getting
mountain dew
and the soda fountain machine
daniel bryan it's still no why was it
they work together they used to work
together so it is daniel bryan yeah
but why didn't daniel bryan acknowledge
knowing him
like he just came right in and was
arguing over them well because he's no
it's all becky lynch thing okay
i'm going to another kfc because this
one
sucks because of you almost kfc i don't
think you're going to find
an acquired kfc yeah most kfc's are
[ __ ] terrible
i'm gonna fight to kfc with last bleeps
and
[Laughter]
welcome the kf mark lane the ethnostate
fan
x4 i just want some chicken
and i refuse to go to churches
because of the you-know-whats
how can i help you i would like to get
five buffalo wings five wings
with french fries
and a diet pepsi please okay he's
watching
okay that'll be
that'll be nine dollars please seems
expensive
but i only have five dollars why are all
these wrestlers so poor
well i mean mcmahon's cutting back
apparently yeah
that means you can't get it eugene
that's it oh that's eugene i'm going to
popeyes
because you're a jerk and next time i
see you
i'm going to tell william regal that
you're rude to me
do you want william to be involved is
that what you want i don't think so
um i don't know if you understand this
or not
mr eugene but um i am in no way involved
in the hiring and firing at kfc
i'm not sure what you expect me to do
about him being rude to you
all right enough we went through the
whole thing it's very long